[Music]
welcome back to cbs this morning as you
may have noticed today is
national wear red day it's a day when
we're all encouraged to wear red to help
raise awareness for women's heart health
cardiovascular disease is the number one
killer of women in the u.s
the disease affects about 44 million an
alarming new survey by the cleveland
clinic found
coronavirus concerns are preventing some
heart disease patients from going to the
doctor
cbs news senior medical correspondent dr
tara narula joins us now she's a
cardiologist
and spokesperson for the american heart
association
tara good morning thank you anthony
she's wearing red is she wearing
pony's right we're all wearing it yes i
am tara
the numbers we just mentioned really are
alarming what what did women need to
know about this disease
well anthony the famous chinese military
leader wrote in the art of war
know your enemy and know yourself so one
word awareness
that is how we're going to win this
battle women need to understand
this is their biggest health threat so
if every woman whoever's listening this
morning put down your coffee stop what
you're doing and remember these three
things
cardiovascular disease kills one woman
every 80 seconds in this country
it kills more women than all forms of
cancer combined
and it is the leading cause of maternal
mortality
this is a disease that affects women of
all ages
all backgrounds so the same way that
it's ingrained in women to get her pap
smear
or her mammogram we need to start to
have women
understand that they need to know their
cardiovascular risk and have a
discussion with their doctor
starting early what are the risk factors
for women tara
well they're certainly the traditional
ones that you've heard about so
hypertension
high cholesterol obesity diabetes
smoking
alcohol family history but then there's
ones that many women don't often think
about so early menopause
migraine polycystic ovarian syndrome
lupus rheumatoid arthritis depression
anxiety
and finally a really important one
things that happen to a woman during
pregnancy so gestational hypertension or
diabetes
pre-term delivery pre-eclampsia all of
those things are going to raise her risk
so a woman should start being screened
at age 20.
she should know her numbers and by those
we mean blood pressure cholesterol body
mass index and blood sugar
and she should know her family history
boy tara you sort of answered the
question i was going to ask you what age
20 seems so young and does it matter if
you have
heart history bad heart history in your
family
i'm surprised by the and as twenty was
young
yeah i think what's so surprising to
people and what we try to educate them
about is that the seeds of
cardiovascular disease are planted so
early
and so much of it can be silent until
the day that you have your heart attack
or your stroke
but those that disease process is
starting at a very early age
tara why do you think so many women
ignore symptoms when when they get them
i want to know what are the symptoms
well so i can answer both symptoms
obviously most common
is chest pain pressure burning squeezing
but certainly women can also have
shortness of breath
decreased exercise tolerance fatigue
nausea lightheadedness passing out
jaw pain arm pain back pain all of those
if they're new
or they're concerning should signal a
woman to speak up and talk to her doctor
and as far as why they ignore them i
think they may not recognize
that this is could be signs or symptoms
of cardiovascular disease
but also women tend to not prioritize
their health particularly their heart
health and they downplay things they
prioritize their children
their work everything else so we need to
have women move themselves up to the top
of the list
but one other important thing anthony
and gail is that as a medical community
we also downplay we know that if a woman
arrives at the hospital she's going to
wait longer
than a man to be seen for chest pain
less often she's going to get aspirin
or guideline directed medical therapy or
diagnostic testing
this is a big problem i have a lot of
patients telling me my doctor told me
i'm just
anxious i'm just stressed out when in
fact they have a real problem
so awareness needs to happen on both
sides yeah and women need to keep
speaking up and pay attention to your
bodies thank you very much tara
always good to see you